douze communes et des territoires
différents dont il faut désormais penser
l'aménagement de manière harmonieuse
pour y parvenir
saint-quentin-en-yvelines élabore son
plan paysage un outil pour répertorier
tous les éléments du paysage de
l'agglomération qu'il soit naturel
urbain ou agricole cette réflexion
servira ensuite dans l'élaboration des
futurs documents de la collectivité
comme le plan local d'urbanisme
intercommunal
on est en train de penser l'aménagement
de notre territoire pour demain plutôt
que de continuer un peu aménagés chacun
dans notre coin chacun je dirais dans sa
ville
eh bien ça va nous obliger à repenser
les choses de façon beaucoup plus
globale puisque à l'échelle d'un
territoire
la réflexion sur le plan paysage débute
par une phase de diagnostic une étude
menée par un cabinet à laquelle sont
associés les saint quentinois mercredi
20 mars ils étaient une vingtaine à
participer à une réunion publique
d'information l'occasion d'échanger sur
leur vision du paysage
ce qu'on aime bien quand même un sac en
papier qu'il ya quand même beaucoup d
espace arboré ce qu'on souhaite res et
surtout éviter de minéralisée les sols
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de place
aujourd'hui qui sont malheureusement
plutôt garni de pavés plutôt que d'armes
on a un site historique patrimonial sont
morts pas qu'on aimerait beaucoup
conserver y compris son environnement et
ses paysages et d'autres sites d'autres
lieux d'autres square fait il ya
beaucoup d'endroits intéressant à
sauvegarder à mettre en avant qu'on a un
passé historique qui est important avec
un point supplémentaire qui remonte au
moyen âge c'est à dire le lieu dit des
trois bornes où était rendu la justice
et qui se trouvent sur notre territoire
mais qui n'est pas indiqué ni valorisé
pour recueillir ses avis sur le paysage
saint quentin en yvelines a lancé une
plateforme participative les habitants
et usagers pourront y exprimer ce qu'ils
souhaitent voir conserver améliorer ou
transformés en postant des photos et des
balades urbaines seront également
organisées dans différents lieux
remarquables du territoire et une fois
la stratégie élaboré un plan d'action
sur le paysage est prévue pour 2020